one 20th century French thinker whose
work I particularly enjoy reading but
sometimes also find frustrating as well
I'll talk about that in a moment is
Jacques Lacan and he's somebody who we
associate with the psychoanalytic
tradition he was a practicing
psychoanalyst in France oftentimes
getting in trouble with his own
Association because of the innovations
that he was engaged in but he also fits
into the broader spectrum of of what we
can call continental philosophy in
general and his work has been used in
and abused indeed in many areas so I'm
gonna talk about my own interest in
Jacques Lacan where that came from and
why after you know several decades I'm
still reading him and rereading him and
occasionally using him referencing him
and writing on him so my initial
introduction to Jacques Lacan came in
part through my my mentor Garth Gillen
who was a philosophy professor at
Southern Illinois University the guy who
I eventually did my dissertation with
and I took a lot of courses with with
Garth and Garth was a really interesting
fellow he was he was kind of withdrawn
from the department until a new crop of
graduate students got there and he was
close to retirement he'd actually earned
not only a PhD in philosophy but he'd
gone on and earned a master's in
theology and went on and did his work in
in educational psychology I believe got
a doctorate and that as well and then
began doing practice and and some of his
practice was you know theologically
oriented he was a deacon and
administered to migrant workers but a
lot of it was actually once he became
certified in it was it was in terms of
psychotherapy and and he got into that
originally through reading in a Freud
and Lacan people liked that but then he
he just read very widely he was a great
person for emphasizing the knee
for theory to actually connect up with
real life and when he retired from being
a philosophy professor he actually
opened a psychotherapy practice out in
Pennsylvania and that I believe is what
he's still doing today I haven't kept in
touch with him over the last five years
or so but he brought Lacan in as a
reference point quite often in his
classes and so you know it was it was
good you know I should read this guy you
know and I started reading Lacan but I
started reading the way I think a lot of
people do with with this book the eighth
ke and this is you know like it says a
selection it's not the full 8k and
there's some you know pretty wild stuff
in here and I'll talk about that in just
a moment but I think this is you know
very useful for me as a student you know
it fit in with a lot of the other stuff
that I was studying having to do with
you know incorporating phenomenology
structuralism you know dialectical ways
of going about things and in
psychoanalysis and what I found really
cool about Lacan is he also knew the
grand philosophical tradition he wasn't
just somebody who had discovered some
theory and was was interested in
applying it so you know studying with
Garth and he actually did teach a summer
class one time just on Freud and Lacan
with a little bit of Melanie Klein and
Anna Freud and Charles Winnicott also
thrown in as well which was which was
cool to get introduced to and I actually
I'll tell you a funny story I remember a
fellow grad student being in there and
you know we're walking there's a break
in the class we walk into the bathroom
and he's just shaking his head and I
said what's the matter and he said oh
this stuff doesn't make any sense
whatsoever I don't know this isn't
really philosophy and I talked to them
and realized that for him philosophy was
the analytic philosophy and I said oh
buddy you're gonna have to like adapt or
get out of the class because it's you
know you're reading Freud right now
wait'll you get to the Lacan stuff it's
not gonna let up and the strictures of
analytic philosophy that you're used to
the ways that they format stuff that is
philosophy but
way broader than that so you got to
either open your mind and try to take
this in and see what you can get out of
it or this this probably just isn't for
you and he actually ended up dropping
the class but the rest of us had a great
time and you know Garth would bring
Lacan in his other classes and there
were quite a few of us that we're
reading Lacan and then you know I
graduated and began working teaching in
Indiana State Prison and I was always
you know still reading Lacan and and
you're using some of his insights I
never gave it to students to try to work
their way through even when I taught a
contemporary philosophy class which was
largely oriented towards continental
philosophy I didn't do that but then I
also participated in a higher level
seminar this was for faculty members and
it was at the University of Notre Dame
I saw it advertised and so I applied for
it and it was with Alastair MacIntyre
MacIntyre wanted to look at models of
practical reasoning and he MacIntyre
likes to do things in terms of you know
like looking at three traditions and
comparing them to each other and if you
don't know who MacIntyre is this is you
know probably his most famous book after
virtue if you haven't read it you should
read it I'll talk some time about my
interest in McIntyre's philosophy as
well MacIntyre also wrote this book the
unconscious in which he goes after the
Freudians on so many accounts so it was
very interesting to see that he would be
leading this group this faculty seminar
at Notre Dame on practical rationality
and the three strains of thought that he
was going to examine were going to be
you know rational decision theory and
its roots and Hobbes and Hume
Aristotelian tome ISM right so we do
some Aristotle some some st. Thomas and
then Freud and Lacan and so I applied
immediately and I think I got in in part
I was you know by far the most junior
faculty member participating in it
I didn't have quite you know that
there's so many publications at that
point but I was somebody who actually
knew all three traditions and I was
teaching in a prison and McIntyre was
interested in so I think that's part of
how I got into it and there were ten of
us who were selected and you know they
put us up on campus and and each day for
a couple weeks we would we would meet in
the morning with McIntyre and then we'd
meet in the evening with McIntyre he
gave us a huge reading list most of
which I'd already read fortunately and
then we'd have these these great
seminars and it was very interesting to
find out that McIntyre was himself so
interested in and receptive to some of
the ideas of Jacques Lacan he considered
Lacan to be an innovator as well and of
course that doesn't mean that he
accepted everything he thought that you
know quite a few of the ideas that Lacan
were had were were you know not really
necessary and the way that he he would
frame things was often quite
counterproductive but you know there was
there was a point to it and what
McIntyre was really interested in is the
role that unconscious that is not yet
conscious desire plays in our practical
reasoning you know can we really
understand what all of our desires are
can we gain some insight through
psychotherapy to reshaping our desires
he was interested in harnessing Lacan
for a essentially an Aristotelian
and-and-and Houmas sort of structure and
and program and I think that was you
know a great idea I think laconic is
quite useable in that way and then I
just you know kept studying him on my
own it's interesting because I encounter
you know quite a few colleagues who are
like oh look ha he's just worthless you
know including many practicing
psychotherapist we're like the guy's a
fraud a charlatan and I think that you
know they're reacting to something that
has some truth to it but they're also
throwing a lot
of babies out with with bathwater let's
talk now about lakhan's writings let's
say you you actually you know wash this
and you're like oh I want to study
Jacques Lacan or or you actually made a
stab at trying to study like huh and you
found yourself stymied well you probably
started with the a crate and this is you
know one copy of it this is the
translation by I always forget these
share it in right and this is just a
selection this is not the full 8k so you
do want to you know get a hold of
instead this one which is the more
authoritative version right this is a
Fink's translation and it's got all of
the essays in there and and many of
these are things that Lacan presented at
conferences and they're difficult works
because Lacan likes to show off way too
much ad engage and plays on words and
make his writings deliberately more
difficult than they need to be which is
why I spend some time sort of
demystifying like ha myself in the
writings that I've done I would say if
you want to study Lacan what you really
want are these seminars you don't want
to start with the ickey you want to
start with these seminars they are high
level theory but they're a lot more
readable I'd say more coherent for the
first time reader and they're he's he's
talking quite often about you know
fairly delimited subjects and he's
trying to get them across to students
now these are graduate level and
postgraduate level students of course so
he's not pulling any punches but you
know they're there quite a bit easier to
get through and you know you notice that
they've all got different subject
matters right so you know the four
fundamental concepts that's a very
important one looks like we've actually
got two copies here my wife and I
consolidated our kind of while back this
is my favorite the ethics of
psychoanalysis
this is actually the one that when when
I was doing that seminar with MacIntyre
it was this and the aka that we are
concentrating on you notice you can tell
that I use this a lot because of all the
post-it notes but I mean if you read
through this you're gonna find stuff
that makes a lot more sense at first
than the material in the a critique not
to say that if you don't stick with it
you can't actually make sense out of
what's going on in the a K but you know
it's it's tougher so I would begin with
some of the seminars as a matter of fact
I would actually begin with this seminar
the ethics of psychoanalysis rather than
jumping you know into the the first
seminar he also has a number of
occasional books this is one that I
particularly like where Lacan who grew
up you know with a cat in a Catholic
household and in France you know says
that religion is is in some sense
completely false he's an atheist but he
also thinks that the atheism that
dispenses with Christian ideas is is
vapid and and doesn't really get at you
know the psychological dimensions of
human being a strange position to take
isn't it except if you read his his a K
and his seminars you'll see why he he
holds such an interesting stance there
are many people who are critical of
Jacques Lacan coming from all quarters I
mean you can get people from analytic
philosophy saying this stuff doesn't
make any sense it's just crazy
Freudianism you know psychoanalysis is
is is to be rejected and this goes a
long ways back right and you can find
people within the psychotherapeutic
institutions saying oh Lacan that you
know he's a fraud he's a charlatan he
just said a lot of stuff that doesn't
make any sense you can't actually put
this into practice and now to be fair
there are practicing you know lakhani
and psychoanalysts and they have not
just remained
content with what Lacan said they
actually you know tried to put stuff
into practice and some things they're
like well Lacan was wrong about this but
he was right about this I think that
Lacan tends to get a lot of bad press
not so much just because of his own
predilection for writing in an obscure
way but because of the superficiality
and sometimes being completely off-base
nature of much of Lacanian theory right
and by that when I say Lacan Ian I don't
mean what Lacan himself actually said
did wrote thought I mean what you know
people who are doing film criticism or
cultural criticism or pick whatever you
like it's usually some sort of criticism
are using of Lacan and and that stuff
varies from like the totally dead-on
great use of theory which is fairly rare
down to the crappy you can tell that
like this person doesn't understand
Lacan it can and can barely rub two
ideas together and get a spark but it
got published in some some journal a
much much of the use of Lacan for for
film studies is like that you know they
totally misunderstand the mirror stage
or you know other key Lacan concepts you
know the difference between the
imaginary symbolic and real they mess
all of that up and so you know just like
Nietzsche I think is not to be evaluated
primarily on the basis of the asinine
things that some of his followers say
you really shouldn't evaluate like huh
based on what it is that that everybody
else is saying using him you should
actually read Lacan himself and if you
think it's nonsense and gobbledygook
after that that that's you know fine so
that that's that's an important
consideration I mean I think you should
I'm not saying that we should just
appeal to authority here in the sense of
a fallacy but when you know when
somebody like Alistair McIntyre takes
Lacan seriously that's probably a sign
that there really is
thing of philosophical merit there too
to take on evaluate see what you think
of I think some of my viewers might be
interested well what do I actually get
out of Lacan and I would say that that
part of it is not just you know
particular ideas that he has but I do
appreciate his general approach which is
synthetic it's attempting to to make
sense out of our experience using tools
from philosophical concepts from you
know therapeutic constructs trying to
bring these together in some sort of
coherent you know approach I think
that's really cool that that's what I
try to do in my own philosophical
counseling and coaching that's what I do
when I'm working with psychotherapeutic
professionals you know for example
trying to adapt philosophical concepts
and to psychological constructs or
helping trainers train better so there's
kind of like a agreement an approach
that I like I do think that that his
insight that the unconscious and I do
think there is an unconscious is
structured like a language is a
brilliant insight and that means that
we'll never really exhaust it and it's
got these structures that we can explore
but we're never fully getting to the
bottom of it I think he's also right
that some of these things are in fact
culturally let's not say just culturally
relative but but in rasa nated in in
culture and and at the same time we
don't want to just you know slip into
kind of a vapid multiculturalism we do
have a Western culture that you know has
some sort of key hallmarks and
highlights to it and that is part of our
you know vast unconscious that we can we
can bring to light I think his
discussions about desire are
particularly helpful and interesting the
notion that we have an imperative to
desire and and to enjoy pleasure that
that especially here in consumer culture
you know we should take a close look at
that I think he has a very realistic
idea of what you know psychotherapeutic
treatment would would look like he's not
aiming for
you know the some of the things that
that were very popular at the time
Eagle integration you know partners
having mutual orgasms together he's more
like listen things are screwed up and
and when you come to me and you're on my
couch or sitting talking to me you're
coming in because things are messed up
for you so we're not going to like look
for some sort of perfect epistemological
clarity before we proceed let's let's go
on and we're not gonna you know take you
know pure happiness or bliss or being
totally integrated as our endpoint you
know you can you can keep doing therapy
as long as you want but at a certain
point we're gonna terminate it and that
point is gonna be when you're you know
functioning well enough that that you
can understand the narrative that you're
in and maybe transform it a bit we're
not going to aim for for bliss or
perfect happiness and I think that you
know the ways in which you know again I
really do love this book I don't agree
with it on every point but the ways in
which he examines are you know long
tradition and options of moral theories
really quite quite brilliant so I like
that stuff I find his discussion of the
various registers quite quite helpful I
think it's a bit incomplete you know my
registers I'm talking about the symbolic
the imaginary and the real so I you know
I'm in agreement with with the people
who say you know we should take virtue
ethics which is really philosophical
therapy and something like spiritual
counseling and psychotherapy and draw
those all into one effective sort of you
know theoretical and practical complex
and soul account is an important
dialogue partner for me in doing that
he's not the only one you know I also
like quite a few other
are people within the psychoanalytic
tradition and I like some psycho
therapist outside of the psychoanalytic
tradition but he is somebody who who I
think is well worth studying and so
there you go